big nba night last night and uh
uh i thought a perfect person for that
would be
uh nba writer for nba.com mr mark medina
to join us and tell us all about it mark
how are we doing i'm good uh good to
chat with you yeah it's good to chat
with you too um
there's a there's a a run of games here
i'm almost calling it hell week for the
miami heat right it started with the
chicago bulls
last night it went to the milwaukee
bucks and they had every opportunity to
take the first two legs of this series
before heading to
new jersey or the nets tonight the
brooklyn nets i call them
tonight
in kevin durant's return and then the
philadelphia 76ers but
talk to us about the ending of that
basketball game 20 seconds to go tyler
hero has the ball and the lead and they
can't get it done in regulation yeah
it's really surprising that that
happened because the heat um you know
they've had some ups and downs the last
few years but do you know one of the
calling cards is that they're always
resilient they're disciplined they make
smart decisions
and you know that didn't happen um so
i'm scratching my head because
uh the reason why they're in you know
the top of the eastern conference
it's because i usually master those
things i mean
speaking with mark medina from nba.com
um
i mean a four-game road trip like this
it's disappointing yes because they
could have they really could have stolen
one in in milwaukee before heading to
these next big games um but that kind of
loss maybe on this road trip could that
could that spiral into uh a devastating
finish to this thing because i mean
these are the teams that they're going
to have to buy for in the east
if they're going to get to an nba
championship
yeah um i doubt it only because i think
the heat are resilient team look i think
that they very well could lose to
brooklyn tonight they could lose to
philadelphia but i would think that that
would have more to do with kevin durant
coming back tonight and philadelphia
they they've looked unstoppable ever
since they've gotten james harden and
that so far
that pairing with joel embiid has been
pretty much seamless um so you know in
fairness to miami before their loss the
bucks you know they were on a four-game
winning streak you know they had gone
through a five-game winning streak
before now uh to dallas so i think for
the most part they've been consistent
but i think to your broader point the
eastern conference is wide open here and
i would still give
the edge to philadelphia and brooklyn
because they're the most talented teams
on paper there are recipes for them to
be combustible because of health and
chemistry uh question marks with the new
rosters
um but on talent itself they have the
edge and so where miami you know has to
be consistent is relying on that heat
culture and i know that you know people
outside of miami roll their eyes but it
is a real thing that they've been able
to you know be on top of the eastern
conference not only because of having
jimmy butler and
and kyle lowry but you know they have a
really good infrastructure from top to
bottom
and that's what they have to tap into if
they want to get out of the east
uh the brooklyn nets
like you mentioned bring back kevin
durant tonight after being away for
for a bunch of games um
his his reemergence uh what kind of
difference and it shockingly enough it
it's pretty easy answer to this but what
do you think his his impact is going to
be initially coming back to this team
yeah i think it's going to be immediate
the the
the intriguing and uh comforting thing
for the nets with kevin durant is that
you know look he's obviously had a lot
of injuries these last few years and
coming off the achilles but when he's
been on the floor
um his numbers are actually better than
his pre-injury with his achilles and so
as long as he's there you know i think
they're the favorites to come out of the
east i think the question mark
moving forward is can he sustain a clean
bill of health
long term um as well as you know what's
kyrie irving's status going to be you
know there is this gray area now where
you know new york is con has talked
about uh lowering its mandate but
there are some stipulations that that
doesn't necessarily apply to workers in
new york um so it remains to be seen
when kyrie can play in home games but if
kevin durant at least is available uh
they're gonna you know still be the best
team in the east but that's been
you know an uncertainty this season
because he has missed so many games yeah
i mean 32 and 31 as of right now right
in the eighth position right you see
what the
back stretch of the season can look like
for him and whether they get into a
place where they don't have to play in
that playing tournament because when you
bring it down to one game
you know we talked about the lakers last
year if they got in and it was a one
game type of deal
you never know what's going to happen in
one game you could have a bad shooting
night you could have all this and you'd
be out of the conversation yeah and
that's the blessing and the curse of the
nets have right now they're very
top-heavy so kevin durant and kyrie
irving can camouflage all their issues
but if one or two of them are out like
they don't really have a lot of good
depth i know they have some decent
players but i don't think it's
collectively enough
to win games consistently you know you
mentioned the lakers i think
specifically in this season it's it's a
little bit different where
okay you still follow the old ads you
don't bet against lebron james but as he
has still been playing his absolute best
in his 19th season at 37 that hasn't
been enough for the lakers still to win
games even when he's on the floor so
i think the nets are in a different
position than the lakers but it's still
this high risk high reward that yeah
they have the the path to get to the nba
finals but they also could lose on the
plane tournament if injuries strike to
uh kevin durant the worst possible time
yeah yeah it's uh it's what made that
playing tournament so interesting ever
since the bubble uh a few years back
okay uh the philly trade right the the
big trade that that was made for james
harden uh finally sending ben simmons
along to the nets
we've seen three games now one back at
home last night the 26 points nine
rebounds nines nine assists uh you know
everybody else contributed they
dominated the knicks once again
i mean what what do you say three three
games in it's been against the likes of
the timberwolves and the and the knicks
but
how much is that playing into this and
how quickly the successes looked early
on
yeah i think that um you know when you
look at both parts uh with brooklyn and
philly i think it was a win-win for both
i think in philadelphia's case
you know i know that they had to give up
a lot to get james harden and you don't
want to under-rate some of the depth
that they sacrificed with having a
really good shooter in seth curry at
least having another uh big with andre
drummond that can you know relieve joel
embiid if he gets into foul trouble um
but the reality is they were in a
position of some weakness where ben
simmons wasn't going to be playing at
all this season like he just made it
clear he was never going to play in a
sixers uniform so uh just by virtue of
the fact that they have now an all-star
on the floor who's available and one
who's really good in james harden um
shows that yeah this is going to work
out now
i think when you look at james harden
historically though he is really good in
the honeymoon period he does the right
things
um but
there are question marks of two things
how
much long term would he be willing to uh
deal with whatever sacrifices with joel
embiid he's had a checkered past with
playing with other star teammates with
doing that and then i think the other
thing is the health he has struggled
with injuries the last two seasons and
even if he is playing really well or
doing the right things now in
philadelphia
that's another concern um that health
could uh take a turn for the worse for
him and so i think that
all illustrates the point i was making
earlier with brooklyn and philadelphia
that um it's very high risk high reward
so i think from a chemistry standpoint
this season there aren't going to be any
issues maybe there are next season but
uh the health the health part is
something that's an unknown yeah well it
always is you never quite know
especially when you're playing
the basketball position uh
or or game uh two more questions around
philly
i mean when the trade was made i mean
there was a lot of jokes made around
james harden who has never been able to
finish a playoff series in the in the
head coach who's been in scenarios where
they've been up 3-1 and these were two
guys that have both been
exactly what you don't want in when you
get to playoff time and now they're part
of it do they cancel each other out or
is this is this a real concern around
either one of these guys not being able
to get it done come crunch time
yeah i think generally for both guys
there's a lot more extenuating
circumstances that explain the
shortcomings but i attach that narrative
more to james harden than to doc rivers
i think in fairness to james harden you
know them losing to the warriors look
they were a dynasty team and they were
the team with the houston rockets that
uh were most successful at leaving the
warriors vulnerable when they had kevin
durant along with steph curry and clay
thompson draymond green but i think
there is something to be said with you
know james being able to know how to
coexist with teammates and i think and
this ties to the health standpoint he
has a track record of wearing down the
post season because his workload is so
heavy
in the regular season part of that's
been by design because you know those
teams that he's played for names needs
james harden to play his absolute best
but it's also i think a reflection of
him uh you know not
willing to make those necessary
adjustments i think in doc rivers case
look he's not blameless uh specifically
when the clippers blew that 3-1 series
lead in the bubble but i think a lot of
it had to do
with uh historically
either injuries with chris paul and
blake griffin coming up at the worst
possible time or in this case with the
his last season with the clippers you
know personality is not meshing and you
know specifically paul george not
playing well uh not to say he's
blameless but in the pie chart i would
put him maybe third and fourth where
when you're looking at james and the
reason for his shortcomings uh you know
his own uh shortcomings would be at the
top of the list for that we're speaking
with mark medina nba writer from nba.com
we'll get you out of here on this
question uh i i think a very welcome um
surprise uh to this trade where you
ultimately thought with james harden
coming in there would be less
opportunities for tyrese maxi
but he's exploded right he he has really
taken advantage of this and has been a
big part of utilizing the opportunity
with this trade yeah i think that this
uh this is a reflection of his growth um
you know he's been
really uh you know helping the sixers
there and it also shows
why they were validated and being
beholden to hey we're not going to deal
tyreese maxi in these ben simmons james
harden negotiations at the 11th hour
you know the nets were trying to get him
uh and you know thankfully the sixers
held firm on that they did have it have
to give up you know other sources of
depth as i mentioned with seth curry and
andre drummond but
you know tyreese maxie is the real deal
and i i think the sky's the limit for
him
well the warriors uh seemingly are
heading down a different path from how
they've played and started this season
uh is there any worry out west right now
about the warriors uh and their their
championship
uh dreams and goals
i don't think internally there is uh you
know look they they've been missing
draymond green for an extended period of
time i think that they would be worried
if they got any sense that draymond
green wasn't going to be coming back
for the rest of the season of playoffs
uh he's obviously been such a game
changer on the defensive end for many
years now and while the warriors were
able to sustain his absence for at least
the first few games um you know the
it wound up catching up to them but
there is optimism that he's his returns
pretty imminent and i think the you know
the other potential source of weakness
is that they don't have a lot of size
you know kevin looney's fine but
he's a role player and james wiseman
it remains to be seen when he'll return
and he had an up and down rookie season
so when you talk to people around the
league some people give
the phoenix suns the edge because they
have that size advantage with having
deandre ayton and having a really good
backup in javel mcgee but internally
so long as draymond green is back the
warriors are optimistic because they can
plug dream on that center and they feel
like they're really skilled enough with
their small lineups that won't even
matter uh because they have not only you
know the obvious answers with steph
curry and koi thompson but they have a
really good blend
of young and veteran players that can
play and
offensively and defensively in multiple
positions
um that that won't wind up catching up
to them but you know what we'll wait and
see the suns are the real deal they're
very well balanced um so it should be a
fun playoff matchup presumably in the
west finals yeah that would be that
would be something it'd be fun to watch
chris paul against that team once again
all right mark thanks for taking time
and joining us and uh educating us about
everything that's going on in the nba
right now hey thanks so much for having
fun talking hoops with you yeah you too
mark medina everybody nba insider and
writer for nba.com um
very interesting stuff hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here